you've had people that we sadly missed
along the way
you had the great prince on your show uh
i have a good i have a
great prince story prince one time
prince is coming on the show and his
his manager calls and says hey prince uh
would love a ping pong
to play ping pong on the show i go okay
uh we'll get a ping-pong table no
problem so he comes on the show we have
the
never brings up ping pong doesn't talk
about it never brings it up
doesn't even mention it i go whatever he
crack he crushes he's awesome
he's great that's the end of that and a
month later i'm at dinner and i get a
text
and i go it says from hi this is
prince's manager
prince wants to meet you right now at a
club
called spin in new york city uh it's a
nightclub it's a ping pong nightclub
wow what so i go to my friend go i gotta
go
prince wants to play me in ping pong
he wants to meet me on 23rd and i go i
gotta go so i get in the cab i go to
this place
i go down the steps uh downstairs and i
go
hi i'm i'm here to see um in the girls
print yeah he's in this
the private room back there behind the
curtain i go okay
so i go in i open this curtain and who's
standing there
a prince in a double-breasted uh
like crushed velvet suit and uh he's
holding a ping-pong
paddle and he goes you ready for
and i go uh yeah this is so surreal
there's no one else in the room
just me and prince so i go uh oh i guess
i go he goes do you want to warm up i go
it doesn't matter i mean i'm not even
good at ping pong but i'll play with you
and he's like
uh oh here we go and so he's he's he
serves and he gets the point and he goes
one's it i go oh we're going to talk
smack here we go let's go prince let's
go let's play now now i'm like ready
to play prince i'm like let's go so i'm
trying to play back i'm not good at ping
pong
long story long uh he's crushing so he's
like
game point i go okay and he hits the
serve
and it's like and it's one of those
perfect ping-pong the things are
spinning
flames are coming off the ball and it's
coming and it hits
that one corner of the ping-pong table
you know that's impossible to hit back
and he hits the thing and go and he goes
i go oh my gosh you won you won you know
let me go so
i look over to pick up the ball i come
back
and uh he's gone he's gone
and i don't know that well so i'm like
prince great and then is he hiding under
the table so like print
prince it was so weird i go
and i walk out and there's like a velvet
rope and it was kind of swinging back
and forth a little bit it sounds like
batman was there or something
and then questlove who's our band leader
here you know from the roots
heard about this ping-pong game and took
a cab over it and he actually saw
prince's limo
uh outside and uh he went up to it and
he goes
uh wait did you guys already play what
happened prince rolled his window down
he goes
ask your boy and then they just peeled
off and then
i i never saw him again
i love that you're kind of in a
ping-pong basement like you're calling a
dog
just going prince
[Laughter]
i didn't know i didn't know if he was
hiding or what it was bizarre bizarre
you